- [Instructor] Imagine
that all the Earth's oceans
disappeared for a day.
And imagine that you being the
excellent Explorer you are,
decided to go investigate.
You'd travel across the continental shelf,
down the continental slope
and across the abyssal plain.
You'd see gaping trenches
running deep into the ground,
and mountains taller than any
mountain on the continents.
And you might wonder,
what causes such dramatic
landscapes to be formed?
Earth's lithosphere, which
is made up of the crust
and the upper part of
the mantle, is broken up
into large puzzle piece like
chunks called tectonic plates.
These tectonic plates move around slowly
over millions of years on
the section of the mantle
below the lithosphere, which
we call the asthenosphere.
There are two types of tectonic plates,
oceanic plates and continental plates.
The continental plates,
as you probably guessed,
are the ones that make up the continents.
The oceanic plates are the ones
that make up the sea floor.
The main difference between oceanic plates
and continental plates
is the type of crust
found on each plate.
Oceanic crust and continental crust
are made out of different kinds of rock.
The continental crust
contains a lot of granite,
which is an igneous rock.
This means that it was made out of rock
that was once molten.
The oceanic crust has
a lot of basalt in it,
which is another kind of igneous rock.
The difference in the kinds of rock
that the crusts are made out
of means that the oceanic crust
is denser than the continental crust.
If you took a cubic centimeter of the rock
from the continental crust,
it would be about 2.7 grams.
A cubic centimeter from the oceanic crust,
on the other hand, would
weigh about three grams.
While this difference in density
might not seem like much,
it completely changes how
tectonic plates interact.
The high density of oceanic crust
causes oceanic plates to
sink into the asthenosphere
a bit more than continental plates do.
When an oceanic plate
collides with another plate
at a convergent boundary,
it always follows this rule,
the denser plates always dives
beneath the less dense plate.
When it's an oceanic plates
and a continental plate converging,
the denser oceanic plates
is the one that dips down.
And when it's two oceanic
plates that are colliding,
the older, denser oceanic
plate will move under
the newer and less dense oceanic plates.
And over time, the denser plate
will be recycled into asthenosphere.
The place where the plates collide
is called a subduction zone.
This bending of the denser plates
under the other creates a trench.
The deepest one is the Mariana Trench,
which is located where the Pacific plates
dives under the Marianna plates.
The trench is about 11 kilometers deep.
The plate that sinks into asthenosphere
often has some water and
fluids trapped inside of it.
These fluids heat up and
bubble to the surface.
The hot fluids can cause
sections of mantle rock
to melt into magma, which then rises
to the surface and creates volcanoes.
And you might be wondering,
if the sea floor is constantly
being destroyed then what
keeps the earth from shrinking?
Well, new sea floor is
constantly being created too.
This happens when two
tectonic plates move away
from each other at a divergent boundary.
When two plates diverge
in the middle of an ocean,
it creates a kind of
underwater mountain range
called a mid-ocean ridge.
As the plates move apart
at mid-ocean ridges,
magma moves up, cools and forms
a new younger lithosphere.
You can think of this process
like a really slow conveyor belt.
New ocean sea floor is made at the ridges,
and moves away from them
over millions of years.
This means that the oceanic crust
that is closest to the
ridge is the youngest.
And as it moves away from the ridge,
the crust gets older and older.
As it ages, the crust becomes
cooler and more dense.
And eventually it dips back down
into the asthenosphere at the trenches.
The sea floor is perhaps the most
unexplored part of our planet.
So if they do drain the
ocean and you go for a walk
at the bottom of the sea,
I hope you'll tell us all
what it's like down there.